Until recently the vast majority of the
world population worked on farms and the
total production of the world's economy
was mostly the total agricultural output
and this output, it was limited
by the fixed size of the land.
The total output of the economy
did not change a lot year by year.
The size of the pie was fixed.
The world was a zero sum game
in such a stagnating world,
the only way to get better off is
if someone else gets worse off.
If you take a bigger piece of the pie,
someone else's get smaller.
If you want more food than conquering,
plundering and stealing
our great strategies,
your neighbor's loss is your gain.
This was the state of things
for thousands of years.
Society's invaded each other
constantly to get more pie.
Economic inequality was extreme.
Some had all the pie they wanted while
others who had to live with the crumbs.
Then the industrial revolution
happened and everything changed.
We developed machinery, better
crops, better fertilizers.
Agricultural output skyrocketed,
but we didn't just produce more food.
Every industrial set to explode.
In terms of productivity from 1700 to
1870 the production of iron in Britain
increased 137 fold.
The industrial revolution led
to a previously unimaginable
increase in economic
output.
This altered the nature of our society's
economic growth changed the world from
a zero sum game to a positive sum game.
We had found a way to create a bigger pie,
but not only a bigger pie,
but a pie that was growing bigger each
year. More people could have more.
At the same time, this development
is spreading and continuing today.
Antibiotics kill bacteria. Our plans
deliver energy. Cell phones connect us.
Planes let us travel
cheaply. Fridges, store food.
Continuous progress in all sectors of
the economy seems normal to us today,
but the change from stagnation to economic
growth really was the most drastic
shift in human history.
How was this possible?
At the very core of this
massive transformation
stand new ideas that lead to
innovation.
Innovation has many different definitions,
but in the context of this video,
we mean better solutions to existing
problems and solutions to problems we
didn't know we had.
The more you innovate,
the more complex and interesting problems
you discover as your wishes and needs
evolve.
The average citizen in Norway 250 years
ago might have wanted some really good
shoes. 150 years ago, maybe
a bicycle 80 years ago,
a car 30 years ago,
cheap air travel and so on.
Once we get what we want,
we don't stop.
We can see how we can improve things
even more and how to make things even
better.
The new positive,
some world has existed for 0.1% of human
history and we have yet to get used to
it.
It has a consequence that feels really
unintuitive in a positive song world.
It's in your personal selfish,
best interest that every human
on planet earth is well off.
It's good for you.
If people in obscure parts of countries
you've never heard of are prospering,
there is a genuine selfish argument
for making the world a better place.
In a positive sum world,
the more people are well off,
the better your own life is.
This is because of the
nature of innovation.
It is fundamentally driven
by supply and demand.
The supply increases when more people
have the freedom and education to
contribute. They become
inventors, researchers, engineers,
or thinkers that come up with new ideas.
The demand Friday's increases.
As people get richer and
can pay for new solutions,
they increase the size of
the market for innovations.
Innovation follows incentives,
so naturally if many people want
to and can pay for something,
it will get the innovators
attention and energy.
Improving the lives of those who are
worst off has a multiplying effect.
It increases demand for ideas while at
the same time making it easier for ideas
to be produced. Let's take an example that
interests all of us. A cure for cancer.
If there are 1 billion people in the
world that have the wealth to pay for
cancer treatments innovation,
we'll follow this demand.
So hundreds of billions of dollars
have been invested in medical research.
This had a huge effect,
but we're still nowhere near to
curing all forms of cancer today.
Every sick person in the world dies of
cancer and you might be one of them.
Now,
imagine if demand were higher.
Imagine instead of 1 billion people
being able to pay for a cure for cancer,
there were 4 billion or 7 billion.
Imagine how far medicine
could have developed if we
didn't invest it seven times
as much in curing cancer.
On top of that,
there's so much human potential
being wasted right now.
The work of a poor farmer in a
developing nation is not useful to you,
but if he becomes better off,
his children might spend that time in
the university developing things that are
useful to you.
Instead of having some hotspots of
innovation in the developed world,
we would have many hotspots
all over the world.
The research output of humanity would
be many times what it is right now.
Could we have cured cancer by now?
If that were the case,
well maybe if we spent seven times as
much on research had seven times as many
people working on this and the
global network of medical research,
things would certainly be further ahead
than they are now and this is the core
of the argument. The more people
want the same thing that you want,
the more likely you are to get it.
That is what it means to
live in a positive sum world.
You didn't gain more piaf
poor places staple. Instead,
you get more pie.
If Paul places get richer,
contribute ideas and grow the global pie.
She likes space travel.
Imagine they were billions of people
in Africa and Asia with their own space
programs and demand for satellites
and moon bases and cities on Mars.
Do you like being alive?
A few billion people paying for medical
research could literally save your life.
It's in your interest for people
around the world to become better off.
The faster we get to this version of the
world, the better for you personally,
no matter what your motivation is,
working on a better world
is a very good thing to do.
For others and for you,
this video was a collaboration with Max
Rosa and our world in data and supported
by the bill and Melinda Gates Foundation.
If you want to help us stay
afloat to make more videos,
you can support us on Patrion or
get some of our fancy posters.